heute am 17 Geburtstag von Vladimir
bombarderovic Putin ja
happy
Moment
ich habe das nur gemacht um zu testen ob
irgendwer so doof ist mitzusingen
das kann doch nicht wahr sein naja sagen
wir mal das war aus Höflichkeit
70 70 geburtstag und hat dann natürlich
heute richtig groß gefeiert und zwar mit
all seinen Freunden war klar ja
viele haben aber auch Last Minute
abgesagt weil sie an die Front mussten
oder sowas was schenkt man dem Mann er
hat doch alles also außer der Ukraine
vielleicht einen schönen Reisegutschein
nach Den Haag einfache Fahrt als Idee
nur als Idee
tatsächlich Klassen Anspruch und
Wirklichkeit bei Herrn Putin immer
weiter auseinander seine Armee muss eine
ukrainische Region nach der anderen
Räumen und immer mehr Russen trauen sich
offene Kritik beziehungsweise mutige
penela Streiche wir am Grab von Putins
Eltern in St Petersburg ein fingierter
lehrereintrag appelliert ihr Sohn
prügelt sich mit dem Sitznachbarn und
droht die ganze Schule in die Luft zu
jagen handeln sie
ja das ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel
verlangt von seinen Eltern oder aber
klar nicht so schlimmer als
Problemkinder mit Atomwaffen da sind wir
uns völlig einig selbst Putin Treue
kreml-fans kritisieren seine Taktik oder
schlagen vor Gebiete doch vielleicht
erstmal zu erobern bevor man sie
annektiert auch im Infokrieg erlebt der
Diktator also Rückschläge und dreht
gleichzeitig immer mehr auf sie glauben
gar nicht was man im russischen
Fernsehen gerade alles über den Westen
lernt
in Deutschland wird den Menschen
nahegelegt nicht zu duschen wann kommen
die Flohfallen zurück weil Schulanfang
geben sie dir ein Lehrbuch wie wird man
schwul
Spongebob hatte wie man so schön sagt
ein Coming Out bemerkenswert ist jedoch
die Tatsache dass diese
Zeichentrickfigur eigentlich asexuell
sein sollte sie haben ein Bordell für
Zoo viele eröffnet könnt ihr euch das
vorstellen für so viele in Dänemark es
ist ganz legal man kann dort hingehen
und keine Ahnung eine Schildkröte
vergewaltigen
nennen sie mich ein Romantiker aber ich
finde man sollte die Schildkröte vorher
wenigstens zum Essen einladen
so ist der Westen experten sprechen von
der gefährlichsten Phase des Krieges
zumal jetzt Karl Lauterbach persönlich
eingreift ja Carl Twitter Zitat wir sind
im Krieg mit Putin tja hat er
inzwischen zurückgenommen weil wir ja
nicht wirklich Kriegspartei sind außer
im sogenannten energiekrieg und da läuft
es leider gar nicht gut Bund und Länder
konnten sich beim großen Gipfel am
Dienstag auf original nichts einigen
erst streiten wochenlang Lindner und
Habeck und jetzt das hat Olaf Scholz
nicht mal gesagt wer bei ihm Führung
bestellt der kriegt sie auch ja wieder
nun ja
keine Einigung beim Wohngeld beim 9
euro-ticket bei den ganzen
energiedeckeln nichts der Scholz muss
sich langsamer Fragen als Wasser in die
Geschichte eingehen will oder als wer
liebe Zuschauer bundeskanzler Helmut
Scholz hat von dem Doppelpunkt
gesprochen gestern
was ich so geil finde dass sie dafür auf
den Zettel gucken muss
[Applaus]
Helmut Scholz ja komm immerhin sie hat
sich den Nachnamen gemerkt dass die
halbe Miete noch hat der sogenannte
doppelwumms von Olaf Scholz nichts
erreicht also außer dass halb Europa
scheinbar sauer auf uns ist aber klar
das muss man zugeben als als hohler
Marketing sprechen ist er natürlich
durchaus catchy ein Doppel Wumms
doppelwumms Doppel Wumms Doppel Wumms
Doppel Wumms sogar doppelt
hauptsache irgendwas Wumms eine
sogenannte doppelwumms-kommission soll
jetzt an diesem Wochenende quasi die
Quadratur des Wunsches schaffen also den
gaspreisdeckeln aber mit sparanreiz und
gleichzeitig irgendwie sozial gerecht
viel Spaß
umso bitterer umso bitterer meine Damen
und Herren dass die Bund länderrunde
sich noch mal um Wochen vertagt hat kein
gutes Signal klar niemand will dass
wieder so gehudelt wird wie neulich bei
der gasumlage aber ich würde schon
behaupten dass es irgendwie eilt
Niedersachsen ist Ministerpräsident weil
fand hinterher trotzdem das dass das
sinnvoll gewesen ist was wir hier
miteinander diskutiert haben und die
Grundlage dafür bieten wird dass wir
demnächst dann hoffentlich insgesamt mit
einem Konzept aufwarten können hör doch
auf
ein Konzept also das wäre natürlich ein
Traum
was hat er gesagt es wurde die Grundlage
gelegt für demnächst hoffentlich
insgesamt ein Konzept vielen Dank auch
ansonsten ist da nichts rumgekommen am
Dienstag außer jede Menge
parteipolitisches Getöse und sich
aufgeblasen warum wegen der ollen
Niedersachsen Wahl am Sonntag ja und da
hört der Spaß aber wirklich mal auf
Freunde
entscheidungsvakuum wegen Niedersachsen
also wegen einem Land in dem genauso
viele Mastschweine Leben wie Menschen wo
die beliebtesten Sportarten Schlick
rutschen Teebeutel Weitwurf und Trecker
Fußball heißen wegen Niedersachsen einem
zugegülten Acker wo das Grundwasser so
verseucht ist dass der Kaffee morgen
schon braun ist bevor er durchgelaufen
ist die heute-show fordert Niedersachsen
Wahl aussetzen gern für immer
man nur so als Anregung
und das sage ich obwohl heute ungefähr
50 Niedersachsen im Studio Publikum
sitzen ja die erkennt man ganz einfach
an ihren Gummistiefel jedenfalls
oder andere Idee wir legen alle
Landtagswahlen auf einen einzigen
Sonntag denn Parteipolitik braucht
gerade kein Mensch jetzt ist wirklich
Pragmatismus angesagt es ist ja so die
Leute im Land haben völlig zu Recht
Existenzängste und Nebenkosten sind die
zweite Miete es ist ja so
gleichzeitig gleichzeitig verbrauchen
private Haushalte aber mehr Gas als in
den Vorjahren im Worst Case droht so
gasrationierung gefolgt von Firmen
Pleiten es müsste man den Bürgern
deutlicher sagen und es ist so schade so
ärgerlich dass die Energiespar Kampagne
der Ampel so ein langweiliger Rohr
krepierer ist hier original Plakat sind
schon gesehen Liebe duschfans wenn so
schon anfängt duschfans Schnarch da muss
man sich doch mal knallige Plakate
ausdenken und die passende Ansprache für
jede Altersgruppe
hey Kinder wisst ihr eigentlich wie viel
Strom euer Fernseher verbraucht macht
sofort die Kiste aus oder ich reiße Elmo
den Kopf ab was
kein Mitleid ich habe Elmo immer gehabt
so bis jetzt ist das wie sie sehen eine
ausgesprochen lame Kampagne von der man
als Bürger so gut wie nichts mitkriegt
da muss mehr kommen zum Glück haben
viele von uns den Ernst der Lage
trotzdem erkannt seit 20 Jahren betreibt
Rolf Vogt nach eigenen Angaben Europas
größtes Weihnachtshaus inklusive
Weihnachtsmann Lichterketten und 650.000
Lämpchen wenn nicht alles geht müssen
wir eben von den 650.000 nur 300.000
anmachen
ja ja das ist der Spirit meine Damen und
Herren ja rechnen Sie mal nach wenn
jeder von uns diese Weihnachten nur
300.000 Lämpchen anmachen
hat Putin schon verloren man sieht es
uns nicht an aber wir sind diese Woche
32 geworden also das wiedervereinigte
Deutschland ist 32 geworden haben sie am
Montag auch die einheitsfall in Erfurt
gesehen ja was für eine deprimierende
Veranstaltung meine Güte wirklich jetzt
hören Sie mal reingesteppt haben sie mal
reingesetzt schwarze Bühne dunkle
Klamotten getragene Musik das schaffen
wirklich nur für deutschen es gibt
eigentlich was zu feiern aber die Show
dazu sieht aus als wäre gerade ein
Flugzeug abgestürzt wirklich irgendwas
zwischen Totensonntag und Poetry Slam
wie immer mit total Bedeutung
schwangerer Choreographie hier zeigen
sie glaube ich wie die Treuhand hunderte
ostunternehmen in den Abgrund gekickt
hat und dann singt ein Reinhard Mey Klon
alle noch tiefer in die Depression mein
Opa sagte er fährt nicht gerne in Osten
ja recht hat er dein Opa Spaß
zusätzlich gab es noch eine fette
gesangsparty fürs Volk draußen auf dem
Erfurter Domplatz immerhin aber selbst
da selbst da wurde leider nur so
getragenes Zeug performt
[Musik]
ja
also you raise me up das Race Stein
nicht gerade vom Hocker oder kann man da
nicht wenigstens mal was weiß ich nicht
was zeitgemäßes spielen wozu die Leute
an so einem Festtag auch mal abgehen
können ach haben sie ich habe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geht doch
viel besser oder ja bitte warum nicht
in die Lage ist ja so einerseits gibt es
so viel über das wir uns am Tag der
Einheit gemeinsam freuen können die
Erfolge der letzten 32 Jahre
gleichzeitig sind aber aktuell auch
Anzeichen für mehr Spaltung nur noch 39%
der ostdeutschen sind laut einer Umfrage
mit unserer Demokratie zufrieden
im Westen sind es noch 59 Prozent
Tendenz aber stark fallend ebenfalls
bedrückend laut Umfragen steht die AFD
in den neuen Ländern bei 27 Prozent und
das obwohl die gelernte spalterpartei zu
den aktuellen Krisen keinen einzigen
Lösungsvorschlag zu bieten hat dafür
Hetze neudings sogar gegen geflüchtete
aus der Ukraine hier mit schöner
Reaktion von Karl Lauterbach während
ukrainische Nobelkarossen vor deutschen
Zahnarztpraxen stehen und nur keiner
sich auf Kosten der deutschen
Beitragszahler die Zähne richten lassen
wissen viele Deutsche nicht mehr wie sie
angesichts der gestiegenen
Lebenshaltungskosten selbst ihre
Grundnahrungsmittel finanzieren sollen
i feel you Karl I feel you ja das war
was war das denn für eine Theorie
Ukraine haben die ganze Invasion nur
vorgetäuscht um sich in Deutschland die
Zähne machen zu lassen
warum also räumt die AFD im Osten
trotzdem schon wieder so ab tja wohl
auch weil man unermüdlich gegen die
Russland Sanktionen agitiert die in den
neuen Ländern besonders kritisch gesehen
werden dazu muss man wissen 60 Prozent
der Menschen dort können nicht zum
Sparen zurücklegen auch nicht für
Energie also damit was ich falsch
verstehen das ist kein Grund Putin
durfte zu finden aber zur Kenntnis
nehmen muss man das schon und sich
vielleicht mal beeilen mit dem
gaspreisdeckel hier Bernd höcke
Bernd höcke auf seiner Alternativen
Einheitsfeier der natürliche Partner für
uns als Nation der Tüftler und Denker
der natürliche Partner unserer Arbeits-
und Lebensweise wäre Russland
wie schön tüfte bernd hat seinen
natürlichen Partner gefunden toll er
möchte dass wir uns der Russischen
Föderation anschließen ganz in der
Tradition des alten höcke stalinparks
oder wie ist der noch mal dafür 27
Prozent dafür klar ist nur eins an Alice
weidels Redekunst liegt garantiert nicht
eben kommt mir der Friedrich Merz
entgegen und wissen Sie wie der reagiert
der guckt zur Seite der guckt plötzlich
weg sagen sie den mal er soll sich mal
anständig benehmen und vernünftig grüßen
das ist ein vernünftiger
parlamentarischer Umgang wo leben wir
eigentlich
mal ernsthaft mal ernsthaft wie traurig
muss dein Leben sein
wenn du dir wünschst von Friedrich Merz
gegrüßt zu werden
mein Gott ja sie merken alles Weine
kämpft für gutes Benehmen nur wenige
Tage nach der Razzia in der AFD
Bundesgeschäftsstelle wegen Verdachts
auf Untreue aber sowas interessiert
afd-fan nicht die freuen sich lieber
über erfundene Gruselgeschichten zum
Beispiel von Carsten Hilse der
Ex-Polizist und Bundestagsabgeordnete
hat gerade erst behauptet Robert Habeck
würde bald Schornsteinfeger
unangekündigt in unsere Wohnung schicken
um zu kontrollieren wie viel wir heizen
ja sie lachen aber genau das passiert ja
längst
Objekt nähert sich dem Thermostat
5 gedreht ich wiederhole das Schwein hat
auf fünf gedreht Zugriff Zugriff
so
wir haben uns also eine Sauna gebastelt
wie
steht er nur auf zwei
ja 52 von weitem total ähnlich aus
sorry
ja dann
schönen Tag noch
sie sahen Robert habecks gwpo die
geheime wärmepolizei natürlich
unentdezember schickt er dann Nikolaus
um die Feinstaubbelastung im Kamin zu
kontrollieren tatsächlich ist das
Erfolgsgeheimnis der AFD überhaupt gar
kein Geheimnis sie leben natürlich
weiter von Wut und Angst wovon sonst nur
die Themen die Angst machen die wechseln
halte da musste dich laufend
weiterbilden Martin klempnow leitet den
AFD Ortsverband Erne Eickel heute
erklärt er seinen Parteikollegen die
neue herbststrategie so Leute die
Anweisungen aus Berlin die sind
eindeutig ja wir setzen komplett auf
schluss mit den Russland Sanktionen
Moment das heißt wir sind jetzt für
Putin ja
nein wir sind gegen den Krieg den
Werbung angefangen hat ja im Grunde sind
wir jetzt eine redenspartei
mir geht's genauso aber Leute putin ist
gegen gender das macht ihn zu einem
natürlichen Verbündeten also als ich
zuletzt in Russland war waren das nicht
unsere Freunde ja Opa
wir hören sonst deine Geschichten sehr
sehr gerne aber jetzt geht es um
aktuelle Wut Themen gibt es sonst noch
Ideen also was mich tierisch aufregt die
haben im Supermarkt so frischkäsepakete
die Kosten dasselbe wie früher ist aber
weniger drin da könnte ich ausrasten ja
Dieter das ist auch sehr interessant
aber hat jetzt vielleicht nicht so das
Wut Potenzial wie die impfdiktatur oder
andere Vorschläge so ganz klein steht da
drauf 175 Gramm früher waren das 200
Gramm
Frischkäse verdammt noch mal ja sorry
ich sag's noch einmal alles auf Ukraine
krieg hier der Abgeordnete tilschneider
erklärt uns wer schuld ist Achtung
George Sorge hat mit seinen Methoden mit
seinem Instituten mit seinen Netzwerken
die Ukraine gedreht das wissen wir alle
er den Leuten den Kopf verrückt gemacht
er sagt Soos meint aber die Juden Opa
bitte jetzt Reis geh auf dein Zimmer
Kopf ganz wichtig ja die alten
wut-themen die bleiben diese Liste hier
die lässt sich endlos fortsetzen ja hey
wisst ihr was sagt er auch mal was ja
wir sehen uns die die Partei der
Meinungsfreiheit ja dann würde ich noch
mal auf den Frischkäse zurückkommen
[Applaus]
übrigens
lassen sich von der kleinen Zähne gerade
nicht täuschen von einem Klischee müssen
wir uns dringend verabschieden die AFD
ist eben keine alte Männerpartei mehr
vor allem in der Zielgruppe ü70 hat die
Alternative zuletzt sogar geschwächelt
dafür aber bei den Jungen abgeräumt und
jetzt kommt er eigentlich der Hammer
ausgerechnet die AFD ist die
erfolgreichste deutsche Partei bei
tiktok wirklich ist kein Spaß da muss
was passieren mein Friedemann Weise
Ratschläge in die Fresse mit Friedemann
Weise
[Musik]
auf dem höchsten Durchschnittsalter ist
ganz weit vorne bei der App mit den
jüngsten Usern oh leise Opa schläft Herr
gauland ich rede gerade über ihren
Erfolg auf tiktok hallo
ZDF-Zuschauer denken sich jetzt was soll
ich mit tiktok ich habe eine Digitaluhr
aber medienaffine High Performer werden
bei dem Wort ganz wuschig
bin gleich auf tiktok bin schon ganz
natürlich gespannt
aha dann bin ich gleich nicht auf tiktok
danke für die Warnung und während Söder
noch ganz nervös ist erreicht die AFD
auf der Plattform die jungen Menschen
die Partei benutzt dafür nicht mal ihren
offiziellen Account kann sie auch gar
nicht der ist nämlich seit Mai wegen
Hassrede gesperrt aber die Abgeordneten
Posten munter Clips aus ihren Reden oft
nicht mal unter ihrem echten Namen warum
machen das die anderen Parteien nicht
genauso weil die offensichtlich immer
noch glauben dass man sich auf tiktok
zum Horst machen muss
[Musik]
wir zählen das alles mit unseren Steuern
dr wolfgang Heubisch FDP Vizepräsident
des Bayerischen Landtags klassischer
Fall von Digital first Bedenken gar
nicht nichts gegen seine Moves in
kubickis Stammkneipe räumt er bestimmt
ab aber auch die SPD nimmt auf tiktok
ihre potenziellen WählerInnen nicht ganz
für voll achtung Achtung ihr könntet
schon bald mehr Geld pro Monat bekommen
denn wir haben im Bundestag beschlossen
dass wir den Mindestlohn zum ersten
Oktober auf 12 Euro anheben das heißt
aber nicht dass ihr mehr arbeiten müsst
sondern dass ich eure Stundenlohn erhöht
ja jedem User wenn man den Stundenlohn
erhöht kriegt man mehr Geld obwohl man
gleich lang arbeitet und morgen erkläre
ich euch wie man einen Klettverschluss
zu macht es ist halt nicht leicht mit
den modernen Apps sogar ein Vollprofi
wie Söder verwechselt seine tiktoks
manchmal mit Sprachnachrichten an seine
hallo ich fahre gerade durch Franken und
freue mich auf unser Treffen heute aber
das kann es zum 16.30 sein weil ich
leider so viele Termine habe das ist
nicht ganz einfach ist aber um 16:30 bin
ich da und ich freue mich wenn wir uns
sehen ja Schatz ich freue mich auch
denkst du an das Hundefutter
aber im Ernst die anderen Parteien
dürfen der AFD auf tiktok dich das Feld
überlassen am sichersten wäre es
natürlich wenn die Kinder gar nicht mehr
auf tiktok wären und dazu gibt es ein
ganz einfachen Weg der bei Facebook auch
schon funktioniert hat sobald wir alten
alle auf der Plattform sind sind die
jungen ganz schnell weg deshalb mein
Tipp wenn sich gleich nach der Sendung
alle ZDF-Zuschauer bei tiktok anmelden
und die große mariacron Rollator
Challenge starten ist die Sache morgen
nachmittag erledigt tschüss
so und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe Fans der feinsten Unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere Videos
sehen wollt
das war's super take wir haben es ich
sehe auch echt schnieke aus heute